daar gaan bij ons
de laatste vraag
want de minister zegt
dat provincies moeten met 1 verordening komen
en als ze dan niet luisteren
dan kom ik met 1 landelijke richtlijn
en toen vroeg ik me af
waarom bent u dan niet direct
met 1 landelijke richtlijn gekomen
net als met datacenters
als we zo nodig
ja en dat willen we natuurlijk ook
de regie willen nemen
dus waarom niet direct met 1 landelijke richtlijn komen
en eerst nog afwachten tot
de provincies dat wel allemaal gaan doen
ja dat is dit is
de Heer Gabriël zoals in zijn vorige leven gerelateerde
en als ik dit zo zou poneren
toen meneer gabriëls
erbij zou zijn geweest als gedeputeerde
had hij had hij natuurlijk gewoon
opgestaan met zijn ik niet op eieren gesmeten
niet tegen deze lotus
zo werkt het niet in het huis van thorbecke
dat weet de Heer gabriëls best
het is
echt de bestuurslaag van de ruimtelijke ordening is
dat zijn echte provincies
er wordt op dit moment
veel meer regie genomen dan in de afgelopen
15 jaar ervoor
zelfs zozeer dat provincies
ja we vonden regie wel 1 goed idee
maar ho ho kan het allemaal 1 beetje rustiger dan
nou dat kan dus niet
want we hebben namelijk
heel weinig tijd
om al die fouten
te herstellen die in de afgelopen 15 jaar zijn gemaakt
alleen ik Wil wel
recht doen aan de verantwoordelijkheid die provincies
ook gewoon hebben
en tot het moment dat is gebleken dat zij
die verantwoordelijkheid niet waarmaken
HEB ik ook geen reden om nationaal
de provincies te overroeren